I don't think it's a small trip fine
business and you could buy these
businesses for cheap hmm
find a business that's engineering less
so someone who made the software built
it okay and you could buy these
companies for as cheap as $10,000 or
almost ability to me don't matter but
you can find there's all these quite
like brokers who sponsor this is one of
them you can find these widgets or
whatever you can buy them for one times
revenue and if it's too expensive for
you you can put a small business loan
you can put only ten sit down so you buy
a hundred thousand dollar business that
makes a bet for ten grand and if it's
engineering lead the likelihood that the
pricing is wrong is high yeah
so you literally just need to buy a
product okay and just change the number
on command-f fine Yeah right like
command-f dollars relax all right okay
why put a zero like you know it's like
$1 million $10 mother it's $10 a month
making a hundred dollars a month and
that's all you did people will and
complain to you customers much and
complain to you the numbers will likely
stay the same except for the revenue
will change yeah that is like most
people are shocked by that no it's
always surprising the price elasticity
of most customers like if you have a
good product not even a great product a
good one an average products most people
will pay so much more than you think but
engineers on particular are always
guilty of this absolutely that's the
same thing to you if you are even a
decent marketer or buying one of these
businesses is a huge opportunity for you
think is a you could just jack up prices
you're so aptly pointed out and be if
you can even get like one percent more
efficient and acquiring customers which
mean that and higher prices you
basically build yourself a substantial
flywheel that can really be a
multi-million dollar
[Music]
you